cette techno peut lire dans votre
cerveau littéralement en fait je vous
explique l'idée c'est que vous mettez un
casque c'est un électro encéphalogramme
et ça va venir réellement analyser les
ondes de votre cerveau alors l'idée
c'est quoi c'est pas pour vous et pour
moi c'est plus pour le milieu médical ça
va permettre de faire un diagnostic ça
permet de connaître votre état de stress
l'anxiété voir s'il y a des maladies
notamment comme Alzheimer voire la
dépression ça vient combiner de
l'intelligence artificielle avec une
grosse banque de données ça vient
mouliner ça vient analyser ça devient
grâce à ce casque avec plein
d'électrodes sur votre tronche venir
analyser voire réellement l'activité
cérébrale de votre cerveau et ça vient
de comparer avec une grosse base de
données pour ensuite avoir la
cartographie de votre cerveau savoir si
tout va bien si vous êtes dans le vert
ou alors si vous avez quelques problèmes
vous êtes dans le rouge le résultat
apparaît et c'est vraiment un outil de
mesure destiné aux professionnels mais
je trouve ça génial parce que là où
faire un électroncéphalogramme est un
petit peu plus compliqué aujourd'hui là
vous posez votre test à part s'envole
les résultats ça marche bien c'est une
technologie coréenne je trouve ça
chouette je pense que vous en pensez
mais pour le milieu médical et les
professionnels de santé ça peut être une
très belle solution